you know Cobell harris was a viscerally
unlikable chronically dishonest morally
corrupt thinly-veiled authoritarian and
honestly i'm shocked she didn't get more
support among democrats for that reason
because they tend to go for those types
but they didn't go for harris apparently
and that's why her campaign ended
yesterday if you heard the news she
dropped out they didn't like her why
didn't like they liked her well because
of racism obviously the media has
already figured that out in fact an
article went up in the independent
penning Comella campaigns failure on
racism and this article went up i swear
it was like fourteen seconds after she
announced that the campaign was ending
they already put the article up because
they because they had written it six
months ago probably and they were just
sitting there waiting to publish it so
as soon as she announced it the
bat-signal went up they grabbed the
crowbar broke the glass hit the big red
button deployed the it was racism
article and let me read a little bit
from this article since we're on the
subject title Camela is a cop was a
racist narrative that killed Harris's
campaign dead and whatever you think
about her it's deeply unfair killed it
dead then just kill a campaign killed it
dead didn't kill it alive killed it dead
this is written by frederick joseph it
says there's a saying among there's a
saying that almost every black person in
america is familiar with if you have you
have to work two times harder and be
twice as good this phrase has been
passed down for generations from parents
and grandparents and to young black
people it's not just an explanation it's
a warning America was built for white
people so if black people want something
it will be much harder
it began with subtle racism and
microaggressions such as being seen as
not likable and being called
overconfident and it escalated from
there so this is somebody who uses the
phrase micro aggression on ironically
just so you know who we're dealing with
which I didn't even think that was a
thing anymore I thought using the phrase
micro aggression on ironically it's kind
of like saying you're triggered on
ironically which I figured that people
who are apt to
be triggered by things probably use a
different phrase now because that one
has become so poisoned by the mockery
that has been rightfully heaped upon it
but not for this individual Frederick
Joseph he says and it is it's a
microaggression so if you if you didn't
think that Kamala Harris was was likable
then you're subtly racist you have to
think that every black person is likable
because if you don't now you could think
that a white person is not likable
that's perfectly fine
what about better O'Rourke he dropped
out a lot of people that did find him
likable I found him to be intensely
unlikable better O'Rourke like so many
other people which is why his campaign
was a failure while I was pulling at
0.0% so is that a microaggression is
that racism and if it's not then isn't
it possible that we in in the same
spirit that we find better O'Rourke
unlikable we also find Camilla Harris
unlikable from the start many had fair
questions about Harris's policies the
platform she'd be running on in her
prosecute or record these were all
important questions but nothing that
would ordinarily be insurmountable for a
candidate with her experience at
pedigree with claim and surging support
would also come strategic moves by her
opposition to throw her campaign into
disarray well I can only imagine wait
you're telling me that Camilla Harris is
political opposition tried to throw her
campaign into disarray was this is the
first time that's ever happened it must
be racism your tell about wait a second
Frederick Joseph are you telling me that
the people running against her we're
trying to stop her from doing well what
this is scandalous this is surely the
first time in the history of politics
this has ever happened she's the victim
this is unfair it is so unfair for her
political opponents to try to prevent
her from beating them it's so unfair
let's see what else so he goes on and on
racism racism
I don't think we need to go from there
uh Camilla Harris started out from
behind operating in a system fueled by
double standards she tried to be the
first woman of color to become president
in a country with a legacy of racism she
tried to do it during the xenophobic
presidency of Donald Trump this isn't a
defense of Camille Harris as a
politician nor is it a defense of her
record this is a defense of her as a
black woman who was treated unfairly
defense of black women everywhere who
are treated unfairly the black women who
worked twice as hard and her twice as
good yet still received less now hold on
a second so you're not defending her
record well why not what what Frederick
Joseph what do you think of her record
did you think it was a good record
because if you didn't if you're telling
me that you didn't like her record
either it didn't support her then maybe
you're starting is it starting to come
together for you now you started maybe
starting to see you I see you're not
defending her record well a lot of
people didn't like her record and that's
why she had to drop out are you starting
to see how this all sort of comes
together and then do you like how these
these these race hustlers they just
pretend that Barack Obama never existed
we're just gonna pretend that never
happened we are you really going with
the Americans wouldn't support a black
candidate because of racism three years
after a black president completed his
second term in office is that really
what you're going with this is one of
those things it's like you know what
it's like it's like when people always
say that the I have a black friend
excuse isn't a good defense against
racism it's kind of the classic it's
considered the classic bad defense
against racism but actually I mean it's
it's a pretty good defense it might not
be bulletproof but it's pretty good
because it stands to reason that racists
probably don't have friends that belong
to the race that they're racist against
just like you know if you call a guy an
anti-semite and then he tells you that
well I just got back from my Jewish
friends daughter's Bat Mitzvah it
doesn't mean he's not an anti-semite but
it's pretty good evidence that he isn't
isn't it
it's at least evidence in his favor tack
like it's not even evidence like it
can't even be brought into the
discussion is just absurd of course it
can well it's the same thing with a
black president we're told that well
America had a black president isn't a
good defense against the charge that
America is systemically racist but it
kind of is though it may not settle the
dispute there have to be other things
brought in but it's it's a it's a really
good piece of evidence in favor of the
claim that America is not systematically
racist
and if it isn't if electing a black man
president isn't even evidence that
America might not be systemically racist
then what you're really saying is that
the claim America is systematically
racist is unfalsifiable you're saying
that nothing could be evidence against
it because if that's not evidence
against it then I can't imagine what and
then there couldn't possibly be evidence
because that's about as good a single
piece of evidence that you could
possibly present and if you're tossing
that out well then what you're saying is
it's unfalsifiable which is another way
of saying that your claim has no real
support or basis and so that mean while
cory booker is still in the race isn't
it he didn't drop out yet so we're gonna
race him to pretend he's not there other
words
thing from this article I skip right
past it but they're somewhere in here I
believe he he mentions the claim that
Kamel harris quote isn't black enough
and he gives that as evidence of racism
ants Camille Harris but are you if that
claim was made oh yeah here it is
at one point it even appeared the social
media bots were maliciously spreading
tweets claiming she wasn't black enough
and questioning her ethnicity so you're
saying that white racists were attacking
Camille Harris because she wasn't black
enough that's what you're saying
is that how white racists operate is
that gonna be there no that's not you
know generally when with with that kind
of claim if that claim was being made it
probably wasn't white people making that
claim all right
let's uh
in fact there's a lot to talk about
today but first before we get to any of
that a word from paint your life yeah we
just got our painting a few weeks ago
it's one of our favorite pictures of our
kids they're standing on a dock at the
lake at a lake vacation last year and
the painting is just great it captures
not just the kids but also the
background the lake the environment
every last detail is there it's
wonderful and you can have an original
painting of yourself your children
family a special place or a cherished
pet at a price that you can afford from
paint your life calm this is a true
painting done by hand by a world-class
artist created from a favorite photos
this isn't something that they do like
on a computer
this isn't it this isn't a Photoshop
thing where you could make it look like
a painting actually have a real artist
sit down and paint this thing for you
makes a perfect holiday gift but it's
also great for birthdays anniversaries
weddings you can I give it as a gift to
myself and to my wife talk to us you
could give it as a gift to yourself as
well you choose the artist whose work
you most admire and work with them
throughout the process until every
detail is perfect it's very hands-on
they're very receptive to feedback and
they're going back and forth and they
want to make sure that you love the
painting there's no risk if you don't
love the final painting your money is
refunded great for decor it's it also
it's a work of art as well with paint
your life you get your favorite memories
transform into a work of art that will
be cherished forever forever and right
now as a limited time offer get 30% off
your painting that's right you get 30%
off right now plus free shipping which
is a big perk as well to get this
special offer text Matt 264 thousand
that's ma tt-to 64,000 Matt 264 thousand
by the way did you guys hear about the
the drama at the NATO summit
yeah parently Justin Trudeau was talking
behind Trump's back and then Trump found
out about it and was totally pissed and
he called Trudeau two-faced then he
canceled his press conference and then
Jake told Becky that Dave had a crush on
her and he was all like what and he
people the lunch table were like you
didn't know that
and she was like you and now I'm just
like oh my god there's gonna be so much
drama at Sara's party on Friday because
yes our world leaders are a bunch of
middle schoolers if you didn't know
that's basically how that works although
I did appreciate with with Trump concert
Oh two-faced I did I did appreciate the
joke there I wish that he had been more
explicit with the joke because of course
this is Trudeau we're talking about he's
literally two-faced he's got two faces
one white and one black
so that was an accurate assessment I
wish that Trump had gone all the way
with that with that come back and made
the explicit connection between
two-faced and the black face thing I
didn't hit him quite to it but it was
still um it was a good comeback
nonetheless all right um
it's something else I wanted to talk
about a a freelance writer for the New
York Times and for some other
publications as well her name is Susanna
Weiss and according to her bio she
specializes in feminism sex and psycho
knotek's I don't know what psycho not
excite kind of get a general impression
of what we're dealing with here and she
recently attempted to basically instruct
the unwashed Twitter masses about the
intricacies of consent and the main
thing Weiss wanted us to know is that
consent is necessary in every sexual
encounter even if it's a sexual
encounter via text message so Weiss
tweeted she said ask consent for all
sexual encounters yes even sexting I
just came up with this script you're all
welcome to borrow and then she actually
provided a script of how you might get
obtained consent in order to sext with
someone and her script has the would-be
sexter saying I've been having some
sexual thoughts about you I'd like to
share over text if you'd enjoy that
that's that's the opening line that's
how you get consent now in this scenario
the lucky sex D gives clear consent by
saying okay and then with the blushing
smiley face now what do you do she
doesn't get into this but what do you do
if you if you open
with that I've have sexual thoughts I'd
like to share and then you get back
instead of okay smiley face you get back
like a K with a period just K period
because everyone knows that that's
passive-aggressive
everyone except for my wife actually
because my wife will do that she'll send
a one-word text message with a period
then I always respond by saying what's
wrong are you okay she says what do you
mean
I said well you can't do one word in a
period periods are passive-aggressive in
the year 2019 if it's a one word or one
letter text you got to leave the period
off so I know that everything's okay
anyways she doesn't get into the
specifics there but this is the this is
the the the script for for sexting and
she doesn't she doesn't give us a sample
of what the sexting itself might look
like thankfully but I guess we can use
our imagination now there are of course
a number of problems here the first and
most obvious problem is that the sex
stir in this case comes across like
Spock or maybe a vaguely self-aware
robot you know like greetings life-form
requesting permission to initiate
robotic erotic communication sequence
which which would be a great way to
maybe sweep one of the cone heads off
their feet but it probably will be kind
of weird and tend to freak out any
normal earthling and secondly we have a
sort of chicken and egg problem here
because if you don't you know you didn't
have permission to think sexually about
the other person in the first place and
you certainly didn't have permission to
ask permission to share the thoughts
that you're having so I think a real
sexting with consent script would have
to begin with a neutral greeting
something like Hello
and then work its way very slowly over
many pages and hundreds of introductory
questions to the sexting request so it's
sort of a Socratic dialogue where you
finally get to the sexting part now it's
probably not fair to pick on the sex
expert Suzanna Weiss here because she's
just one small example of a growing
trend with this with this with her
notion of consent this brings to mind
for example a few months ago maybe you
saw the consent condom which would would
require four hands to
open an NBC News said that it makes a
powerful statement about consent more
troubling certainly more dangerous are
the affirmative consent laws across the
country on especially on college
campuses and what the affirmative
consent law says is that any sexual
encounter even one that seems to be
consensual can turn into rape if consent
is not verbal and ongoing now what is
ongoing consent means it means that
throughout the act and really this all
it always comes down to the man
throughout the act the man has to stop
and has to be given continuous and
explicit consent to continue as it's
happening and then there's a consent
checklist over at Cosmo towel ttan which
takes it a step further now at
cosmopolitan with their consent
checklist item number three on the list
and this is a checklist that you go over
before engaging in sexual activity to
make sure that you have consent now
here's item number three on the list is
consent on going before during and after
an encounter or throughout in
relationship after they're saying you
have to get consent for a sexual act
before it happens while it's happening
and also after it's already happened how
does that work exactly who knows but it
does mean that you may become an
unwitting rapist if consent for sex is
withdrawn after the deeds already been
done then planned parenthood which is an
organization that by the way violates
the consent of 300,000 unborn children a
year by killing them without their
consent but they add another wrinkle to
this on their website they say that
consent has to be enthusiastic as well
affirmative ongoing before during after
and also enthusiastic the way they
explain that they say when it comes to
sex you should only do stuff you want to
do not things that you feel you're
expected to do which yes but how is your
sex partner supposed to know if you
don't want to do the thing you said you
wanted to do
and what does it have to do with consent
anyway because if I choose freely to do
something despite not wanting to do it
I've still consented begrudging consent
is still consent the begrudging nature
of my consent does not erase the fact
that it is consent so it's like if I
walk outside of the grocery store and
you know you've got those some booths
set up and they're soliciting money for
whatever literally little-league or
whatever it is and you feel you don't
really want to give to them but you feel
guilty because you still have your
change in your hand with your receipt
you haven't put it in your pocket yet
and then they stop you sir would you
mind helping and you've got insight you
just you give them the money because you
feel guilty now it's begrudging you
didn't want to give but you did consent
they didn't rob you they wouldn't be
fair to give to the little league
fundraiser and then later turn around
and say they robbed you because they
didn't so begrudging charity is not
robbery begrudging sex is not rape but
it is
I think ironic that sex in our oversexed
age has turned into this it's become
laden with rules and stipulations and
fine print and you've got a packet of
information you have to go through and
get it notarized that signatures and
you've got to get a lawyer there that's
what it's become even though we live by
all appearances in a hedonistic amoral
culture so there appears to be some kind
of paradox here
and I think what happened is that we
fled so far and so fast from anything
resembling sexual morality that we
basically came full circle all the way
around the globe and ran into it from
the opposite side
end up with our culture's weirdest and
most significant innovation which is
hedonistic prudishness or prudish
hedonism we've become like this
Frankenstein mixture of Victorian
England and the 1960s
it's not very hard to see how it came to
this because the hook-up culture is not
what it was cracked up to be
it is in fact as people like susanna
weiss realize it is fraught with danger
physical danger emotional danger of
psychological danger spiritual danger
when you put yourself into the role of a
stranger sex toy the pleasure is sure to
be fleeting and it won't be enough to
compensate for the peril that comes with
it so you've got this ever-expanding
list of rules and stipulations and fine
print which is meant to offer protection
from some of those perils but the rules
always fail and so more and more rules
are added but here's the point why are
these rules necessary to begin with
they're only necessary because we've
thrown out the two ingredients or or you
know the three ingredient the main
ingredients that make sex truly joyful
and also truly safe and those
ingredients as much as we hate to admit
it our love devotion commitment also
known as marriage so the Cosmopolitan's
and Suzanne oasis of the world they're
not giving us rules for sex per se
rather they're giving you rules for sex
with strangers who don't give a damn
about you what they're saying is if
you're gonna do this with someone who
doesn't care about you and who you and
who you hardly know well then here's a
whole list of rules to keep you safe
they're trying to spare you from the
danger inherent in giving yourself to a
person who doesn't know you and doesn't
care about you and doesn't love you
but what they don't want to admit is
that the best way to avoid those dangers
is just to not do that to begin with you
don't need to worry as much about the
lawyerly stipulations if you're with
someone that you know you love and you
trust
I mean you know think about with
something like sexting now I'll say on
the record probably not a good idea to
sext anyone even your spouse because
nothing you do on your phone is really
private and so I think everyone would do
well to remember that with everything
they do online and on their phones and
on their computers none of it is private
none of it ever will be so just to keep
that in mind but part of the part of
what Susanna Weis is getting out here is
that well you know if you if you do this
with with someone and you know you've
got to be careful because if it's
unsolicited who knows what's gonna
happen maybe they'll call the cops on
you maybe they'll take your your sext
and they'll put it online and they'll
embarrass you yeah again see those are
the dangers inherent when you're trying
to act this way with someone you don't
know who's not your spouse
at least you know you probably don't
have to worry about the cops getting
involved if you're being flirtatious
with your spouse because marriage
affords a certain security that a
million consent checklists could never
offer
no that's not to say that abuse and
assault and things don't happen in a
marriage of course they do
but verbal consent all of these consent
rules we come up with it turns out that
they don't really amount to much if they
don't begin with the words I do if
you're taking those words out then as we
have discovered
there's really nothing you can do to
make this completely safe
because you are at the end of the day
you are giving yourself over to someone
who isn't committed to you and you
know that they're just using you
now again bad things can happen in a
marriage but you know when it's when it
in the hook-up culture which is what
we're talking about here you go into it
there's really only bad things that can
come of it
if something bad happens in a marriage
if a salt abuse that's where things go
wrong but in the hook-up culture it's
just that's it's designed that way
there's there's no other possible
outcome
you are giving yourself over you are
making yourself vulnerable to someone
who doesn't give a damn
isn't devoted to you isn't committed to
you doesn't even pretend to be committed
to you and who is just using you and you
know that and that's what the
arrangement is all about
all right let's let's go emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Tony
you've said in many shows that eating
dogs is the same as eating other animals
have I said that in many shows I know I
talked about it yesterday briefly but is
that it is that a topic I go back to
frequently eating dogs maybe it is I
disagree because dogs have been
completely domesticated over hundreds
maybe thousands of years it is thousands
by the way some new breeds of dogs would
have zero chance of surviving on their
own all they know is how to love humans
because dogs have basically evolved to
be our pets it seems wrong to turn our
backs on them and eat them it seems
treacherous even do you take the stance
that we can do anything with animals or
is there some moral obligation we have
towards them maybe the bad things we do
to animals are only bad in relation to
ourselves for example if there was a
serial killer of dogs with that person
only be wrong because they they are
themselves being wrathful / violent what
are your thoughts PS I'm not a dog owner
and don't plan to be smart plan by the
way to not be a dog owner no Tony I
don't think there's anything
intrinsically immoral about eating dogs
I my point yesterday is it's a cultural
convention you know you're talking about
how we as Westerners see dogs not
everybody sees dogs that way not
everybody sees them in the same way
um and and you know we we see cows as a
source of food and we tend to cherish
dogs and and not see them that way some
cultures have a different attitude
towards cows is our attitude correct and
theirs is wrong I you know I wouldn't
well if they're worshipping and you know
the the idolatry or worship of animals
is wrong but in terms of which animals
we domesticate and and which we tend to
form bonds with in which we don't you
know that I think is really just a
cultural convention I don't think that
there's anything inherently there's any
inherent morality going on here we do
have a moral obligation to treat animals
with respect obviously all animals we
shouldn't be cruel we shouldn't torture
animals or abuse them but I don't see
any reason why eating a dog should be
considered intrinsically different from
eating a cow or a pig pigs are very
smart animals pigs are social animals
whatever consciousness dogs have which
I'm not sure I mean nobody really knows
how that works exactly inside a dog's
head whatever what sort of awareness a
dog has we know they have some kind of
awareness it's not the same as people
but
I don't think there's any reason to
assume that a dog's awareness and
consciousness and capacity for suffering
is any greater than a pig's I don't
think there's any reason to assume that
so let me ask you this what if a dog
dies on its own let's say your family
dog dies on it you didn't kill it or
anything it's just the dog died would it
be immoral to eat your family dog that
just died
I mean could you articulate any reason
why it would be immoral now your I know
your reaction your reaction is like my
reaction which is that's weird
it might my first visceral reaction is
yeah that is wrong yeah he's not gonna
fight Oh dies not gonna eat fight oh but
that's a visceral reaction if you asked
me to explain it um I couldn't really
explain it why is it wrong look at the
dogs dead it's not gonna hurt him any
he's already gone so I think the answer
is that it again it's a cultural thing
this is just cultural programming and
and and that's why we think it's a
problem in other cultures they would say
what's what's the problem and like I
said yesterday when it comes to the
cultural stuff this is not cultural
relativism that I'm doing here cultural
relativism is saying that each culture
makes up its own moral rules there is no
inherent or objective morality and so
whatever is right in a culture is
therefore right I'm not saying that if a
culture decides that slavery is okay it
doesn't make it okay but there are some
things that that are just conventions
and I think that this is one of them
when it comes to your diet okay that's a
classic example
aside from things like cannibalism this
is a classic example of a cultural
convention and and that's all let's see
this is from Matt says Matt love the
show and I appreciate your insight quick
question how would you refute Buddhism
why does it seem that so many on the
Left are more likely to embrace Buddhism
and go Ravens yes go Ravens that's
interesting question and the short
answer is I don't know the answer to it
because I'm not very familiar with
Buddhism certainly not familiar enough
about it to speak intelligently about it
for very long
so I'm mainly reading your Anna your
email because I'm interested to see if
other listeners maybe know something
about it and want to chime in
and that this is something that I've
thought about it does seem like
obviously there's Buddhism has an appeal
in the West especially among people on
the left why is that exactly it's an
interesting question based on my very
limited knowledge of Buddhism I'll say
first of all that I think you have to
distinguish between Buddhism as a sort
of system of thought and outlook a
philosophy even a self-help method so
there's that sort of Buddhism and then
you have Buddhism as a traditional
religion with metaphysical claims and I
think many Buddhists do practice it as a
religion and do believe the metaphysical
claims of Buddhism but the Western
liberals who find Buddhism appealing the
ones you're talking about they're not
looking at it as a religion they're
going to it for more of the
psychological aspects now
the reason why they would flock to
Buddhism over Christianity I think is
easy enough to see Christianity makes
moral demands
whereas Buddhism Buddhism in the form
that they find appealing does not I also
think that even religious even even
non-religious people have a desire in an
eighth desire for some kind of system
some kind of philosophy that brings
order and meaning to life and so that's
why they're looking at Buddhism but then
I also think that we should acknowledge
that Buddhism as I understand it does
have certain insights into the human
condition insights about suffering about
contentment and this is where I might
start mangling things but I think two of
the main insights Buddhism offers from a
psychological standpoint are one that to
live is to suffer Buddhists were not the
first to think of that one but it is an
important insight suffering is a part of
life okay that's that's important yeah
and then number two suffering is born
from desire so we suffer because of what
we want
in all cases of suffering you're
suffering because something is not
happening that you wish was happening or
something is happening that you wish was
not happening and that sums up all forms
of suffering for human beings it's your
desire for a thing to stop or for a
thing to start as the case may be that
really creates suffering so the Buddhist
says if you overcome desire if you
overcome attachment if you become
unattached from desire if you live in
the present moment while accepting all
that is happening without wanting it to
be different then you'll overcome
suffering and you'll be content and I
guess that's supposed to be Zen and so
on I think there's a lot to be said for
for for some of that especially in our
culture where we we've we have the ad
industry and the media and Hollywood etc
constantly trying to convince us that
you know we should want what we don't
have and we shouldn't want what we do
have and we have this this effect of
desires constantly multiplied and you
turn on the TV and you develop a desire
for something that you didn't even know
existed
before you turned it on and so we're
constantly wanting things we don't have
right and so yes the more that we focus
on wanting what we don't have and not
wanting what we do have the more we will
suffer and yes living in the present
moment accepting it for what it is is a
key to being content and healthy I think
that live in the moment is one of the
wisest cliches that modern culture seems
to seems to enjoy you know of all the
cliches people say I think living in the
moment is actually there's a lot of
truth to that if you can if you can
manage it and this is something that
again this isn't just Buddhism Jesus
talks about this in the Sermon on the
Mount but I think
I think that one of the one of the
problems though with Buddhism is the
danger of making people too detached
even indifferent
because that's the balance
and I think Jesus does a good job of
Jesus does a good job of this but I
think the Sermon on the Mount strikes
his balance
I'm not sure how well Buddhism strikes
it or you want to live in the moment you
can't be obsessed with desires but you
also have to care you should care about
the suffering of others you should care
about the state of the world you should
care about the state of your soul and
there are good things that you should
desire you should desire holiness you
should desire happiness the real
happiness for yourself and for your
family and your children right so maybe
that's where some of the problems come
in but I said that I was that I don't
know a lot about it I'm not going to
talk about that I talked about it for 15
minutes so that's the way this generally
goes and now I will enjoy all the emails
from people informing me that I know
nothing about Buddhism which is
basically true let's go let's see we do
one more here this is from John says
kind sir while I do agree with you
personally on practically all points on
abortion I am still pro-choice on a
governmental level and I see it the
pro-life position of any termination
after conception being equivalent to
murder as a theocratic imposition sons
God the value of human life is arbitrary
so the line of what is or isn't murders
arbitrary as well to call terminating a
blastocyst
murder hinges on the religious belief of
inherent value of human life it's
obvious that many people in the country
feel that at least at the earliest
stages of development in embryo doesn't
equal human life that being the case you
must admit that your standard is is
exactly that your standard and the
imposition of your belief on the other
people will be theocratic even though
science says life starts a conception
science can't assign value to life our
Constitution applying only to citizens
would necessarily exempt this life from
constitutional protections on life
seeing how it could clearly is not a US
citizen
how would it not be the height of
theocracy to force your religious
standards on others using the powers of
the state it seems to meet all
valuations of human life at any stage
and in any form should be for the
purposes of non theocratic state
completely arbitrary and drawn on a
compromise of public consensus can't
wait to hear why I'm wrong well I agree
with much of what you just said there
believe it or not John you say that
without God the value of human life is
arbitrary this is probably true but you
must see the problem for your position
I assume that you still think that
murdering born humans should be illegal
right
not to mention rape slavery kidnapping
theft and so on all of that should be
illegal I assume you would you would say
well by your logic these are also
theocratic in positions as you say
because they all hinge on the belief the
doctrine of the value and dignity of
human life and that doctrine lies at the
foundation of our country it's very much
a spiritual doctrine so we can have this
argument about whether or not America
was founded on Christianity America was
not founded on Christianity that much is
clear but it's also clear that it was
founded on a belief in God on a belief
in the supernatural and that's why it
says in our in our you know founding
documents and the Declaration of
Independence everything they're about
you know created equal everything about
human rights that are inherent to human
beings
well I have never heard of a I've never
heard anyone explain what human rights
could be without some sort of super net
without without introducing some element
of the supernatural into it because
without that then human rights are well
you said yourself arbitrary
where does it come from now you could
certainly argue that without God the
case against abortion is rather weak
because who says that unborn children
have a right to life what does it mean
where does that right come from which
okay fine I agree with you but then who
says that anybody has a right to life
what does it mean for anyone to have a
right to life or it have any other right
to anything else where does that come
from and I'm not sure how an atheist
solves that problem but if you manage to
solve it for born people then I think
you've also solved it for unborn people
whatever you have to do in your mind to
come up with some idea of born people
having human rights and having the right
to be free from murder and torture and
all these things however you do that in
your head without God well I don't see
why I wouldn't apply to to the unborn as
well but if you can't solve it then you
must either say that all laws are
arbitrary and grounded in nothing and
that human rights are a fiction or you
must say that human rights and human
dignity have some other source and I'm
not sure what that other source would be
that's not my problem to solve I think
it's yours but whatever that other
source is if it exists it's the source
from which the unborn draw as well
so I think that's the issue that you
that you run up against now if you want
to take a totally nihilistic approach
and say that life has no meaning none of
this means anything there's no reason
what really why anybody should be
protected for murder or rape or anything
else and but you know we do it just
because it makes it easier on us if you
know it's easier to have a society if we
all pretend that it's wrong to rape and
murder and kill if that's what you want
to argue then we could have that
argument I think you have to make it
clear that that's where you're coming
from as a nihilist who does just doesn't
value human life at all and I admit that
that would be a more difficult
conversation because if we're starting
you know if we do not have a starting
consensus that at the very least human
life has value if we can't even agree on
that then it does make it more difficult
to have the conversation but if that's
not the world you want to live in if you
want to live in a world where things
have meaning and it's wrong to kill
people you know and murderers should be
punished because what they did is
terrible if you want to live in that
world then I don't see how you exclude
the unborn from that I think that is the
arbiter everything to do see it's not me
drawing an arbitrary line I think it's
you
agree that human beings generally should
be protected from these things what I'm
saying is yeah I agree I'm with you so
these are human beings why exclude them
what reason is there to exclude them I
kinda would say that the burden of proof
is on you to come up with a good reason
for excite I think that our starting
point our default position should just
be assuming that all human beings in any
stage of development
to be protected for murder I think
that's our default if you want to draw a
line and start excluding people then I
think the burden of proof is on you to
come up with to explain your reason for
that
and I don't think that you've done that
here but I appreciate the email and I
appreciate everybody for listening and
watching have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me
Andrew Clayton
[Music]